[Musique]
non
aux confins de l'inde et du pakistan
deux cent mille kilomètres carrés de
sable et de stades caillouteuse le
nord-ouest du rajasthan a été surnommé
le pays de la mort tant l'eau y est rare
et les conditions de vie extrêmes
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le désert du thar
ah ah les uns ont ça saute
avec ses 140 kg de bagages et son armée
de porter cette jeune française ne vient
pas ici pour les vacances depuis sept
ans capucine a choisi de vivre dans le
désert par amour pour un indien nommé
pas bout mais ok
après un séjour en france elle rentre
aujourd'hui au pays avec son mari et
maurane leur fils de 6 ans ça va mon
amour oui
le désert m'a tellement manqué mais pour
rejoindre son coin de désert
capucine doit encore faire une heure de
route sur des pistes de plus en plus
cahoteuse
et tout au bout de ce no man's land la
petite maison où le jeune couple s'est
installé
[Musique]
on arrive
quelqu'un vous êtes où si capucine n'a
eu qu'un fils avec pas bout elle a
adopté toute sa famille indienne
à commencer par les enfants qui
l'avaient déjà
[Musique]
pab où il rate trop fort avec une femme
ils sont mariés la force très très jeune
et elle est partie un jour en laissant
les enfants quatre frères et soeurs et
une flopée de cousins pour maurane à 33
ans
capucine à huit enfants à charge
venez je suis la mine à la stib et
combien et où la soeur de pas vous mais
qui ça à nos fils et une fille de pabx
ou in a alors face à mais le shérif ces
famines à ce mes enfants et je crois
pour tuer vos mon grand tu as déjà vu
maurane tout ce petit monde s'entasse
dans deux pièces sans électricité ni eau
courante mais avec un terrain de jeu
illimité comme les gens du désert
la jeune française a appris à vivre
dehors et n'utilise sa maison que pour y
abriter ses maigres trésor là c'est là
où j'ai mes vêtements
voilà tout a été pris tout est sens
dessus dessous
sa réponse ah oui souvent quand je pars
et que j'ai pas fermée à clé les gens
viennent se servir prince qui leur
manquent ils n'ont pas l'impression de
voler pour les empreintes puis ça vient
ça revient pas forcément au début ça me
mettait hors de moi maintenant je me
suis habitué
ce à quoi je tiens vraiment j'ai une
boîte là en métal avec un cadenas ge
je mets puis le reste ça disparaît c'est
pas grave
pour s'installer ici lie à 7 ans
capucine a abandonné ses études
d'architecturé et elle n'a aucun revenu
en france
elle ferait partie des plus pauvres mais
à chaque fois qu'elle revient ici c'est
un peu comme si le père noël débarquer
aujourd'hui elle doit distribuer les
vêtements collectés en france grâce à
l'association caritative qu'elle a créée
et baptisée mal npai du nom d'une déesse
du désert la connaît ici les enfants ça
et j'obtiens c'est pour toi
[Musique]
esaïe regarde ça va bien ensemble
la jupe est assortie au t-shirt tu
trouves pas ça la folie de la mode ne
connaît pas de frontières et capucine
est bien obligé de freiner les ardeurs
j'ai dit un seul tee shirt et un
pantalon il y en a plein d'autres qui
attendent leur tour
c'est clair là on fait une distribution
en première mais enfants ce qu'ils ont
vu arriver avec des sacs et on s'en tire
mal si je leur donne rien mais j'ai bien
dit à chacun un vêtement parce que je
sais qu'ils en ont déjà
le fait d'avoir deux vêtements c'est
assez sinon il les perd 10 ans prennent
pas soin à la boire 2 on en met un
pendant qu'on l'art l'autre ils avaient
eux-mêmes leurs vêtements pour sécher et
puis un jour après quand ils reprennent
leur douche ces échanges jusqu'à qui
suis de vêtements ici ça suffit pour
être très content
[Musique]
pour le retour de capucine sa famille
indienne aussi a mis les petits plats
dans les grands
un menu de fête mitonné par sa
belle-soeur kamla qu'est-ce que vous
avez préparé des bindi super j'adore ça
oui je sais que j'aime ça
[Musique]
faute de réfrigérateur ici tout ce qui
est frais doit être mangé le jour même
et donc réservé aux grandes occasions
sinon sinon je du piment revenus avec de
l'huile et déjà pâti ces faits de la
farine de blé est un petit peu de sel et
de l'eau c'est ouf il n'y a pas de
levure ou deux mots je suis beaucoup de
lentilles on dit on appelle sa dalle et
c'est bon aussi démenti sauf quand c'est
tous les jours en france quand on me dit
je t'ai fait de leurs outils
ça me tente moyennement
[Musique]
enfin tu sais ce que je mange en france
non je ne mange pas des pis ah bon oui
mais tu manges koala tepa mois du chou
fleur dont camus elle ne s'était pas
mêlé chou fleur en face à elle c'est de
voir tout ce qui coûte cher on habite
ici dit la balle mange tout ça parce que
nous dehors le vent brûlant du désert a
fini par faiblir ce soir baboo a coiffé
le turban traditionnelle et inviter
quelques musiciens itinérants à faire
halte chez lui pour faire honneur à la
femme qu'il aime
[Musique]
ici pas de télé ni de radio ces
troubadours sont donc nourri et logé en
échange de leur musique
si capucines à aimer cette culture dès
le premier instant elle a pourtant mis
des années à se faire accepter par cette
caste d'intouchables
l'une des plus isolés en inde bravo
bravo c'est si beau c'est vrai qu'il
arrivait de me sentir seul dans cette
tribu parce que je ne parlais pas la
langue au début j'ai dû apprendre le
maladie je pense que personne parle
anglais à part pas bout il suffisait qui
par trois jours un mariage
j'étais tout seul sans pas allé sans
pouvoir discuter chaleur pesante monde
se moque et moi au début c'était c'était
vraiment dur j'avais produit repartir
jamais quand un bâtiment où j'ai fait le
choix de faire cette vie là j'ai jamais
regretter j'ai eu des moments difficiles
à chaque fois j'ai comparé en dix ans
pour moi c'est aussi difficile de vivre
comme je vivais à paris dans un appart
seule avec un enfant avec tous les trop
ménager mes seuls physiquement et ici il
ya une chaleur docteur qui réunit tout
le monde et qui portent en fait qu on
perd je trouve votre chaise j'aimerais
bien jouer des cours talent mais je ne
suis pas bonne je ne sais pas s'il va zy
les cours talent ce sont ces
castagnettes du désert dont l'usagé est
traditionnellement réservé aux hommes
ici elle est la seule femme enjouée
menacée c'était très bien
non merci mais ce n'était pas bien
celui-ci s'était vraiment bien il faut
que vous m'appreniez pour profiter de la
fraîcheur nocturne tout le monde dort à
la belle étoile après cinq mois chez sa
grand mère française dans une vraie
chambre d'enfant morale retrouve donc le
dortoir à la mode du désert
tu es là mais c'est mina avec maurane et
arrow est trop content moi n'a retrouvé
un petit quizz in riyadh lui a grandi
ici et il n'a donc aucun mal à se ré
acclimater mais capucine aussi a dû s'y
faire parce que babou ne supportait pas
de dormir enfermé
ça c'est mon oreiller
le confort est rudimentaire et
l'intimité toute relative on comprenait
pourquoi nos repas sur la terrasse
même au milieu du désert on n'est jamais
complètement seul ici même s'ils dorment
sur le toit ils ne sont pas très loin
oui ils sont tous prennent les entend
même reflet mais tu sais c'est important
qu'on essaie de passer plus de temps
ensemble
oui mais si on n'est pas que tous les
deux on est quand même ensemble chez
capucines on se croirait aux antipodes
de la civilisation
[Musique]
pourtant à seulement 30 kilomètres de là
ce sont tous les fastes de l'inde qui se
cache derrière les remparts de cette
forteresse de sable
jason moeurs
au milieu du désert une oasis où l'eau
et les richesses n'ont jamais manqué à
l'époque des invasions barbares
les guerriers rajput chargés de protéger
la région en avait fait une citadelle
imprenable
[Musique]
pour asseoir leur puissance ils y
avaient érigé des palais somptueux
certains d'entre eux ont été transformés
en hôtels mais leurs descendants ou y
vivent encore aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre demeure la dynastie
singh descend en droite ligne du
maharadjah de jazz almere et vite ici
depuis 300 ans
un palais des mille et une nuits où
cette génération de guerriers rajput ont
régné sur la province et laissé leur
empreinte
ça ressemble à un musée mais pour le
prince vikram qui a grandi ici ce sont
juste des souvenirs de famille
[Musique]
on
c'est ainsi que mon grand père a tué il
ya 40 ou 50 ans les trois petits bacs
clé là ce sont aux sabres d'apparat on
s'en servait pour faire la guerre mais
surtout pour les cérémonies car ils sont
en or massif
[Musique]
vous voyez celui là on a tué quelqu'un
avec car il ya un trou dans le pommeau
ça veut dire qu'il a donné la mort
désarmé ancestrale que le prince vikram
et même son épouse la princesse nedjma
ont dû apprendre à manier
quand j'étais petit mon père m'a appris
le maniement du sabre avec une épée en
bois quand les hommes partaient à la
guerre il ne restait que les femmes et
les serviteurs pour défendre la maison
et pour une princesse rajput tombé aux
mains de l'ennemi était la pire des
honneurs il fallait le tuer ou se donner
la mort des traditions d'un autre âge
dont certaines aux pourtant au perdurer
jusqu'à une époque récente les femmes
étaient alors les gardiennes mais aussi
les prisonnières du palais
[Musique]
même si c'était les quartiers des femmes
et des enfants
vous voyez les fenêtres elle donne tout
sur la cour intérieure il n'y en a
aucune sur la rue cette partie du palais
était donc totalement cloisonné
lorsqu'il était petit le prince vikram
ne pouvait voir sa mère que dans ces
quartiers on était admis aucun homme
adulte à par le maharajah
et si on est chez les femmes
je vous présente ma mère la vieille
marani y vit toujours et en est sortie
pour la première fois il y à seulement
20 ans
[Musique]
j'avais 15 ans quand j'ai été amenée ici
pour mon mariage et j'ai attendu d'en
avoir 40 pour en sortir
jusque là je ne savais absolument pas à
quoi ressemble et de chazelles mer si on
m'avait laissé le choix j'aurais adoré
sortir mais ça n'a jamais pu se faire du
vivant de ma belle mère la princesse
nedjma n'a pas hérité du mode de vie de
sa belle mère mais de son trésor
ça ce sont les bracelets que j'ai reçus
pour mon mariage c'est très anciens ils
sont en ivoire et en or et sont transmis
de génération en génération
et voilà les bracelets en or qu'on parte
au pied avec les grelots ça aussi ma
belle mère me les a offerts pour ménages
une collection de joyaux d'une valeur
inestimable
vous me dire combien de diamants il ya
sur ce collier 50 peut-être oui 50
diamants non beaucoup plus il y en a au
moins une centaine comme leur grand mère
et leur mère les deux petites princesses
hériteront aussi un jour de ses bijoux
vas-y fais les sonner très bien je peux
essayer celui là
un héritage qu'elles trouveront
peut-être un jour lourd à porter si
elles doivent comme l'exigent toujours
la tradition rajput épouser un prince de
leur caste choisi par leur famille
tourne toi
très joli
[Musique]
dans le désert le jour se lève à peine
à défaut de pouvoir édifier un palais à
la femme qu'il aime pas bout lui a
offert la liberté et en guise de bijoux
de famille
une batterie de casseroles pour
économiser l'eau ici c'est au sable
qu'on fait la vaisselle
c'est un décapant très puissant en tête
le sable ça gratte ou et s'enlève les
autres voilà aussi bien plus de l'eau à
ça va mieux mais pour les grandes
occasions pour le faire briller encore
plus à la fin on fera taille de la
cendre et voilà je trouve ça impeccable
[Rires]
oui on suppose une vrai cadeau c'est
rapide et ça ne t'a jamais manqué le
confort de choisir et j'ai uniquement
pour un confort moi c'est c'est à mon
but c'est sûr que c'était pas mon rêve
depuis tout petit 1 j'avais besoin de
vivre à la dire ça c'est un tout c'est
un tournant avec le reste de ma vie qui
est si fort et si si beau dans sa
simplicité
si on m'offrait un lave-vaisselle
électricité ici je cracherais pas dessus
utiliserait
[Musique]
essai
pour gagner un peu d'argent capucine est
pas beau on construit quelques huttes où
il accueille des touristes
aujourd'hui c'est justement une famille
de français qui vient découvrir le
désert comme à chaque fois
capucine appréhende un peu la rencontre
faire comprendre son mode de vie hors
norme est toujours un défi
[Musique]
régis marie et les deux enfants arrivent
de paris c'est leur premier voyage en
inde
[Musique]
bienvenue chez nous l'année pour les
initier à la vie dans le désert
capucine commence par la visite des
huttes où ils vont dormir
voilà attention à la tête
vraiment bien voilà je vais vous montrer
et walad suivez moi profond des
sanitaires pour nos visiteurs uniquement
quand on veut prendre une douche ont
fait couler de l'eau on porte le sceau
on va jusqu'à l'endroit de la douche
c'est la douche où je suis
et voilà et on se touche comme ça parce
que tu t'es déjà douchez comme ça tu
sais pourquoi on fait ça parce que s'il
n'y a pas d'eau donc pour aller chercher
de l'eau on va avec un tracteur qui est
un grand réservoir derrière on remplit
dans les villages ont fait toute la
route pour revenir alors chaque goutte
après on en prend grand soin mais ce
n'est pas la fin des épreuves pour hugo
en guise de bienvenue
les indiens ont préparé aux français une
spécialité très prisé ici un porridge
aux fruits secs et aux épices c'est
bizarre si la coulure si c'est de la
bouillie pertes à 14 ans hugo rêve
plutôt de sa partir à l'assaut du désert
à dos de dromadaire allait d'abord vers
l'arrière et canaux
[Musique]
pas âme qui vive à l'horizon mais un
paysage lunaire de roches volcaniques
et tout au bout de ce champ minérale une
mer de sable
striée d'étranges traces blanchâtres
zagreb la glace la neige si vous en
prenez une pincée et que vous la mettez
sur votre langue
vous verrez c'est du sel c'est tout ce
qu'il reste du plus grand lac salé de la
région totalement asséché dans ce coin
de désert
il n'a pas plu depuis trois ans et le
point d'eau le plus proche est à
plusieurs heures de marche
alors malgré les secousses tout le monde
s'accroche à sa monture
c'est vraiment génial c'est vraiment ce
qu'on attendait et puis on n'a pas
l'impression de faire un tour de
chameaux pour touristes
mais regardez autour de vous un à 360° y
en a aucun c'est ça qui est vraiment
agréable pour pas bout et capucine non
plus ce n'est pas un exercice
touristique mais leurs plus anciens
souvenirs communs il y à 7 ans c'est
comme ça qu'ils se sont rencontrés il
était chameliers elle touristes et elle
avait loué ses services pour une
randonnée dans le désert
[Musique]
quand j'ai rencontré pas bougé t'es sûr
que c'était l'homme de ma vie et c'était
c'était une évidence c'était la première
chose vraiment sûr de toute ma vie et
lui pareil il m'a dit je t'ai attendu
toute ma vie tu enfin là et est donc
voila c'était plus fort que tout c'est
comme si la vie nous avait réunis pour
qu'ensemble on soit plus fort maintenant
plus rien ne pourra jamais nous séparer
tentes pour moi et puis il ya le lieu
pas
j il essaie de se
je pris ici ils m'incite à aller puiser
ce que j'ai de bons au fond de moi c'est
un dieu du désert les sept soeurs
compris ici qui pour deux mondes mandat
protection pour qu ils protègent les
villages les familles c'est très
important pour pavot et sa famille le
panthéon hindou compte plus de dieu que
d'habitants dans le désert plus de 33000
divinité et quasiment autant de temple
dans l'espoir de voir exaucer leurs
voeux les pèlerins n'hésitent pas à
traverser le pays pour aller demander
prospérité ou santé où dieu qu'il vénère
au chan est un des hauts lieux de la
spiritualité hindoue ici ce sont les
couples qui viennent des quatre coins de
l'inde pour prier la déesse de la
fécondité ira et son épouse pin pannes
ont fait 300 km pour venir jusqu'ici
tenez voici nous offrons pour la ds des
noix de coco des friandises et quelques
billets pour tenter d'infléchir le sort
je peux avoir un bracelet il faut la
tâche est ici pour que vos voeux soit
exaucé
depuis dix ans ils ont tout tenté pour
avoir un enfant
la ds sa chien matin représentent leurs
derniers espoirs
tu as vu le monde qu'il ya c'est que ça
doit marcher non j'espère si on arrive à
avoir un enfant
on reviendra pour remercier la ds elle
doit forcément avoir un grand pouvoir
pour attirer tous ces gens ici on est
allé voir des médecins on appris dans
des dizaines de temples et ça n'a servi
à rien mais avec sacha matin j'y crois
comme elle a donné des enfants à
d'autres on espère que nous donnera
enfin un pis moi je ne sais pas si la ds
va nous entendre
mais je suis venu ici pour alléger la
souffrance une souffrance intime mais
aussi un drame social pour le comprendre
nous sommes allé retrouver ira épine
panne dans le village où ils vivent ici
toutes les femmes sont escortés de sept
ou huit enfants
à défaut d'avoir les siens pinkman passe
tout son temps avec ceux de ses voisines
allez les filles dansaient pour moi non
je préfère vous regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle c'est la fille de ma belle soeur et
toutes les autres aussi elle en a quatre
et elles passent tout leur temps chez
moi elle ça la rend heureuse
et moi ça m'arrange des enfants j'en ai
trop alors quand j'en ai marre je les
envoie à pine panne moi j'adore
m'occuper d'eux je les lave je les
nourris
je leur achète des friandises on joue
ensemble
[Rires]
voilà quelques pâles amène le mois
comment ça va mon bébé mon petit grand
père et à moi
rien qu'à moi tecsys iata vient de faire
un câlin c'est moi un bisou c'est tu me
fais un petit sourire mais derrière
l'apparence solidarité pin panne et ira
sont victimes d'une exclusion qui ne dit
pas son nom
ce n'est qu'à l'abri des oreilles
indiscrètes enfermés dans leur maison
qu'ils acceptent finalement de nous
raconter leur quotidien gamme dans le
village tout le monde dit qu'on a dû
faire quelque chose de mal et que les
dieux nous punissent c'est pour ça qu'on
n'a pas d'enfant
les gens disent qu'on parte le mauvais
oeil alors beaucoup ne veulent même pas
nous adresser la parole
si dans un an n'a toujours pas d'enfant
je vais devoir prendre une seconde femme
ça me fait mal mais c'est une autre
femme lui donne un enfant je
l'accueillerai comme le mien et au moins
les gens reviendront nous voir en inde
ne pas avoir d'enfant est une
malédiction mais en avoir trop n'est pas
beaucoup plus simple à gérer
[Musique]
pour les enfants chez capucine et pas
vous il n'est que 5 heures du matin mais
la jeune française est déjà sur le pont
[Musique]
lève toi
solvay au milieu de la nuit pour aller à
l'école
vu de france ça ressemble à un cauchemar
mais pour ces petites filles indienne
c'est un rêve qui se réalise ici moins
d'une fillette sur deux apprend à lire
et à écrire
maman viens voir alors ils sont comment
ces nouveaux uniformes ils vous plaisent
super oui sont trop beaux moi j'adore le
mien ce moment c'est aussi
l'aboutissement de sept ans de combat
pour capucine l'école coûte cher en inde
et ce n'est que grâce aux dons récoltés
par son association qu'elle a enfin pu
réunir l'argent nécessaire pour
scolariser tous les enfants cette année
alors comment ça se passe depuis la
rentrée vous être contente
les premiers jours on se levait au
milieu de la nuit et du coup on était
près de deux heures à l'avancé
on était trop excitée elle ne peux pas
m'en contente de l'alcool parce qu'elle
a attendu d'avoir 12 ans pour la l'école
et elle pensait pas avoir la chance d'y
aller
pour mina la nièce de capucine c'est un
sursis inespéré
elle aura 13 ans l'an prochain et son
père étaient bien décidés à la mariée
[Musique]
pour le convaincre de la laisser d'abord
aller à l'école la jeune française a dû
lutter pied à pied
aujourd'hui il s'est fait une raison et
il joue même les chauffeurs
moi je sais ni lire ni écrire mes
enfants ils s'en sortiront peut-être
mieux s'ils vont à l'école
pourtant l'éducation à l'indienne
ce n'est pas que du bonheur les enfants
ont raconté à capucine que les gifles
pleuvait à la moindre erreur
elle est donc bien décidé à rectifier le
tir bonjour ce sont mes enfants
tu as vu une blanche avec des enfants
indiens c'est vraiment amer je veux vous
voir parce qu'ils se plaignent d'être
battu par les professeurs il faut qu'on
en parle
les enfants lui ont dit qu'on les
frappaient alors elle ce plan elle a pas
l'air contente
en france vous pourriez aller en prison
pour ça c'est pour ça que je viens
vérifier
elle est en prison pour ça c'est vrai je
ne plaisante pas c'est interdit en
réalité
capucine soupçonne les enseignants de
faire payer aux enfants leur statut
d'intouchable cette caste la plus
méprisée en inde est souvent victime de
brimades
pour en avoir le coeur net
le jeune couple décide d'assister à un
cours
bonjour c'est possible d'assister aux
cours avec ma femme ce sont nos enfants
[Musique]
ça n'a pas l'air si mal finalement
la surprise est plutôt bonne les petites
filles sont au premier rang et
aujourd'hui l'enseignant déploie même un
zèle tout particulier à leur égard
si j'avais eu cette chance quand j'étais
petit je me dis que j'aurais adoré aller
à l'école moi aussi je suis tellement
fière d'elle tellement heureux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais pour que les enfants puissent aller
à l'école
encore faut-il que les parents aient de
quoi vivre alors capucine s'est mise à
battre la campagne dans tous les
villages voisins pour y développer
l'artisanat local
bonjour comment bâtir non ne taquine pas
devant nous on est si contente de te
voir
c'est toujours bon signe quand tu ne
rend visite
si capucine n'est pas vous sont toujours
les bienvenus ici c'est qu'ils sont
considérés comme des bienfaiteurs
bonjour j'ai mal comment ça va ça va
mais respect bonjour ça va bien jaba les
tisserands à bout et capucine sont
aujourd'hui ses plus gros clients
il nous faudrait une vingtaine de tapis
pour le mois prochain
c'est possible 20 c'est beaucoup combien
tu peux m'en faire ils sont une
quinzaine d'ici un mois et demi pour le
reste je vais faire ce que je peux il y
encore trois ans cet homme casser des
pierres pour survivre tisserand c'était
le métier de son grand père mais jabal
lui ne l'avait jamais appris
capucine et pas bull ont incité à
reprendre cette activité et honte en
quelque sorte sponsoriser son
apprentissage à distance rapide que tu
fais on va tous les acheter et donc il
s'est mis à faire à faire affaire on lui
acheter des stocks et des stocks et les
stocks qui nous a donné
il en a fait des plus en plus beaux
qu'on a pu par la suite à nos visiteurs
voilà depuis le vieil homme a pu payer
le mariage de ses deux filles aînées et
scolariser les trois plus jeunes
ça a tout changé pour moi maintenant je
peux passer plus de temps avec mes
enfants et leur offrir ce dont ils ont
besoin
je gagne bien ma vie et je suis fier de
ce que je fais je trouve que ces gens
ont une richesse intérieure est une
richesse culturelle énorme et je veux
les encourager à la faire perdurer
parce que je je sais que c'est à sa qui
se rattachent quand la vie est trop dure
et que tout d'un coup on a envie de
laisser tomber parce que c'était trop
dur de se nourrir on trouve pas de
travail ou de travailler trop physique
la chaleur la seule chose qui les font
tenir c'est d'être ensemble et c'est
cette tradition pour défendre ses
traditions tribales en voie de
disparition
capucine vient de se lancer un nouveau
défi y en avoir un bientôt parcourir le
rajasthan pour aller promouvoir d'autres
talents
on
[Musique]
direction jobs pour comme pour marquer
la frontière avec le désert la ville
s'est mise aux couleurs du ciel
on raconte ici que l'azur des façades
protège de la chaleur éloigne les
moustiques
aujourd'hui la cité bleue est devenu le
carrefour des artisans et des artistes
nomades venus des quatre coins du
rajasthan
[Musique]
capucine escorté comme toujours des deux
hommes de sa vie s'est mis en tête de
convaincre des artistes de venir chez
elle pour les faire découvrir aux
touristes
bonjour bonjour on les appelle les cales
bellia autrefois ses gitanes du désert
charmer les serpents et soigner leur
morsure à l'aide de leur musique et de
danse destiné à envoûter l'animal pour
imiter les mouvements hypnotique du
reptile les femmes ondulent les tournois
de plus en plus vite
comme en état de transe
à mi chemin entre la danse et le numéro
de contorsionniste jeudi adoré c'est
vrai oui d'accord tu m'apprends à toi
car juste un peu d'accord d'accord merci
ça te dérange pas qu'elle mme apprennent
à lancer ce n'est pas que je sois contre
mais tu sais bien ce que les gens vont
penser j'ai pas envie qu'on dise du mal
de toi
sipa vous est loin d'être enthousiaste
c'est parce qu au rajasthan les femmes
qui dans son public sont considérés
comme des dépravés et aujourd'hui des
dizaines de curieux se sont justement
agglutinés sur les toits voisins
dans ce cas on descend sans fermer l
m'apprennent bon ok mais je veux pas que
les hommes viennent mais on ne peut pas
danser sans le joueur de courtage j'ai
besoin d'un musicien
ah non pas d'homme juste un seul nom non
pas question
bon sans musique alors comme ça ça va
c'est donc sans musique et dans une
pièce barricadé que la jeune française
va enfin pouvoir revêtir les atours
dekalb elia pour esquisser ses premiers
pas de danse
[Musique]
si toi mon chéri détends toi je te fais
pas c'est beau j'adore je voudrais
apprendre comment elle fait ça fait
comme ça maintenant fait le tout seul
tout seul oui je te corrigerait
[Musique]
des coulisses à la scène
elle devra encore s'entraîner un peu
c'est beau je peux m'y prendre pour
faire ça tu mets une main au une mamba
et la tête sur le côté mais pour pas
bout ça tombe bien il n'est pas très
pressé de partager le spectacle avec
d'autres admirateurs
au revoir merci une super prof
merci reviens quand tu veux je
t'apprendrai encore
[Musique]
en attendant les soirs de fête dans le
désert capucine se contentent encore de
jouer les spectatrices
c'est la dernière nuit des français sur
place
la danseuse et exotiques
régis ne boude pas son plaisir la
demoiselle finit par inviter ces
messieurs à la récompensé pour ses
efforts
régis se lance dans le désert c'est
comme ça les hommes préfèrent danser eux
mêmes plutôt que de laisser leurs femmes
compromettre leur réputation à une belle
indienne
et puis très rapidement en fait les pas
plus lourd
mon petit fils
on a tout de suite vu la supercherie et
je pense qu'on vivra pas ça nulle autre
part ce soir il ne sera pas le seul à
avoir une surprise babou a fait croire à
capucine qu'il avait organisé cette fête
en l'honneur des vacanciers mais ce
n'est pas tout à fait ça capucine a eu
33 ans aujourd'hui mais c'est la
première fois que sa famille indienne
célèbre son anniversaire
[Musique]
mais
et certains à mon amour merci c'est mon
plus bel anniversaire
après avoir espéré en vain pendant sept
ans elle ne s'y attendait plus vraiment
en un dossier célèbre les anniversaires
en inde je pense que oui dans le désert
non parce qu'on connaît pas la date de
naissance mais pas bout a pris alors oui
c'est que je lui ai répété à plusieurs
reprises un que c'était mon anniversaire
de cette date là et puis il s'en est
souvenu cette année bon anniversaire du
désert
l'heure des adieux a sonné pour les
français mais après s'être demandé s'il
allait tenir deux jours dans le désert
ils n'ont plus l'air si pressé de partir
chloé joue les monitrices de colonies de
vacances et sa mère s'improvise
infirmières juste que je les ai faites
correctement ce vieil indien a fait 10
km à pied dans l'espoir de se faire
soigner et la touriste française a tenu
à prendre les choses en main là il se
trouve que je voyais ce bandage tout
plein de je ne sais pas trop quoi de son
éclat et puis ce monsieur qui révélèrent
d'avoir mal donc au bon ben moi j'ai mal
j'ai amené toute ma pharmacie donc je me
dis que valve va bien servir donc voilà
oh
aujourd'hui le vieil homme repartira
soulagé mais les français ont bien du
mal à larguer les amarres pour eux comme
pour capucine le charme du désert semble
avoir opéré ou à poursuivre notre chemin
et il est certainement plus facile que
pour eux donc voilà c'est c'est la même
affiche
ouais c'est super que dans le babeurre
servir
je suis très émue participent à ce que
parce que c'était une belle expérience
parce que c'était vraiment ce que moi je
recherchais pas ce que parce qu'on a
envie aussi de les aider
ce sera une belle somme
[Musique]
marie régis et leurs enfants ne sont
sans doute pas près d'oublier la
française du désert et sa tribu
quant à capucine son destin appartient à
cette terre elle le sait son histoire
d'amour a fait d'elle une indienne
blanche
[Musique]
on
damas
moi
[Musique]